this is a production of cornell
university
um
okay well i i am really happy to be back
though here in the cornell community
as you can see i have a real long
history with cornell and with lots of
people here so it's it's great to be
back and also great to be back in the
buckler lab working with my my old
friends and
and uh with with tripsycom wild relative
of maze
so um these are kind of what the
these were sort of questions i had when
i first went to simmon i had no idea
what i was supposed to do as the head of
a germplasm bank so i had lots of
questions
um and i asked like what what would a
global network of plant genetic
resources look like and
simmets germplasm bank is part of
an international network but how does
that function
um
and how can an international germplasm
bank
help
smallholder farmers part of the draw for
me to go to simmit was
oh i get to work with farmers i get to
help people
after spending my whole career in
academia now i can actually help people
so i was really interested in how am i
going to do that
um
this next question is a seed bank a seed
more
this is a big
little big issue that came up in the
genetic resource community and i'm going
to get into more details on it when i
hit that part of the segment of the talk
and then um
[Music]
at the end i'm going to talk about what
were my objectives ultimately uh for the
time that i spent at summit and and how
did i do did i did i reach those goals
and then at the end some gratitude
so
um the goal is to have a fully secure
and accessible plant genetic resources
for food and agriculture pgrfa we talk
about that all the time the the
international uh banks of the cg system
were mandated under the
the uh treaty developed by fao so
um
where there is a potential for a
multilateral flow of germplasm and
knowledge among the participants and
these participants are basically
intended to be in a grand sense all
human beings on earth
so
the goal is this connected system
where
you could start
with
right down with a family a family seed
reserve
and that farmer could back up his or her
seed in a community seed reserve in
their own village and that in turn that
collection could be backed up to be kept
in a national or regional durham
pleasant bank which in turn would back
up to perhaps an international germplasm
bank or
um could back up in
the big germ plaza bank uh above the
arctic circle in svalbard but this was
kind of you know
the big picture idea
however the reality
in in 2021 is that these lengths are
very weak
except for that last one the link
between the international banks and
salbard is is quite
quite strong
and um
also many national uh systems like the
us for instance they have a backup at
svalbard so that is a very strong link
and i'm not going to talk about that
today what i want to talk about are the
other links
so i'm going to illustrate that with a
story of a partnership that we at the
simmit maze collection developed through
a
usaid funded project called the bueno
milpa project with icta which is the
national
uh germplasm system of guatemala associ
is an ngo
in this particular area of guatemala and
the farmers that they serve
so we're going to talk about how we
developed this particular part of the
chain
so we're going to dive into the western
highlands of guatemala
over there where the little arrow is
it's a beautiful the landscape is
incredible the
mountains the clouds it's just
incredible but it is also a place with
with just incredible
malnutrition and poverty
so the starting point is that um
traditional systems uh artificial feed
storage systems local farmers
are actually eliminating their food
security in an area greatly affected by
malnutrition and poverty
community seed reserves could provide a
very effective way to
improve that seed security offering a
safe accessible source of high quality
locally adapted seed for annual
plantings and in emergencies such as
crop failure due to local
weather conditions
and what i found
is that the people in these communities
actually have a better
understanding and appreciation for the
concept of a seed bank
than
than people in
industrialized societies who have no
idea or they hear about svalvard and
they talk about armageddon
these people have many armageddons every
five years they can lose their
completely lose their crops so
they actually um you know there was a
great appreciation for this concept of
having seed banks
but when we joined this project
uh we were tasked with
these questions are the existing
community reserves in the kuchimatani's
mountains in this region are they living
up to the expectations and if not how
can we make them better now those there
was a whole net or there is a whole
network of community reserves in this
region
functioning on over a decade of funding
from the norwegian government they've
put in
millions of dollars to do this
and uh
but you know
they could always do better and we were
tasked with this these questions how can
we make them better
so the farmer's methods of storing green
and seeds kind of look like this um they
use foreign cribs
or uh metal silos there's quite a few of
those kicking around
usually not full of grain but full of
other things like clothing
and shoes and things like that but um
they also are used um and they uh store
in husks
uh or in sacks like you can see here
so the the community reserves they offer
an alternative storage option and this
is one of the inside one of those
community reserves and showing an
example of what a local agrobiodiversity
collection so we're not only talking
about maize we're talking about all the
props and the medicinal plants in an
area and they uh make these generalized
collections
but the the core of a community reserve
is this thing called the private
accounts and what how this works is that
when a farmer uh harvests in january or
february uh you know of course they've
got their grain for consumption and
maybe a little bit for sale uh but they
they have the seed that they save for
the next cycle and they bring it to the
their local community reserve they have
their own little uh container they take
out the seed that had been sitting there
for the year before they put in the new
seed and then they plant and the cycle
repeats so this is the basic
way this this functions they have other
services where they some some of them do
mass selection community participatory
breeding and they do have
improved seed also they have emergency
grain in a silo which anybody in the
community can use in the case of a
complete crop failure
the problem the problem is that these
little houses
are have very high humidity and
uh you know they were equipped with all
the basic equipment and one of the
things they had were hydrometers they
all had hygrometers on the wall and as
we were visiting them we would glance at
the hygrometer and we'd go oh my god 88
humidity in here
and um that 59 that was that was like
wow great um but usually it was 88 82
into the 90s so this seemed to us to be
a big problem
so the you know in this case the
relative humidity was 94
and when we put these little indicator
cards inside the flasks everything's
pink okay so even the seed is
and as we started interviewing people in
the community series and asking what
their problems are invariably insect
infiltrate infestations and mold those
are all problems for them
so this key fact is something that i
always keep in mind that longevity of
seeds
storage it's very it's highly sensitive
to both moisture content and temperature
and generally the duration of the seed
viability is reduced by half
for every one percent increase
in moisture content
or an increase of six degrees c now so
you can see that yes temperature is
important but moisture level is critical
and during the course of building all
these seed reserves there are about 12
to 15 of them
they got better and better at
controlling temperature but they didn't
do anything about the humidity
so
there's the problem what would be an
economical solution and we came to the
the conclusion that
you know remember these places don't
have electricity so they can't just whip
out the dehumidifier and bring down the
humidity no they can't do that so um how
about if we try lowering the community
inside those containers and not the
whole building well how could we do that
so at this time
um i went back and i realized that i had
heard something
about uh these things called drying
beads
and so uh lo and behold in india they've
started using it in
these things called drying beads they're
desiccant
and uh require very little power to use
and i thought hey maybe this is
something we should try to investigate
so yes indeed the drying beads which we
ended up calling cuentas
or or also perlitas like little pearls
we call them that too um
when you use these drying beads um
and keep the seed dry they're completely
resistant to insect infestations and so
they have this model called make the
seed dry keep the dry make it dry keep
it dry and and that's kind of like the
the mantra of the the dry chain and this
is something that was developed at um
university of california davis by kent
bradford and i started having
discussions with kent about how can we
apply them in
community research that seemed possible
no one had tried this
in all of the americas they were already
using them in asia
because the the person who the innovator
who realized that drying beets could be
used for seed drying uh he's based in
thailand and so they had started using
them in asia but they had not started
using them anywhere in the americas so
we said hey why not let's try it let's
see what we can do
so we also needed a fast way and an
expensive way to monitor the humidity
and um the hort lab at uc davis had
developed these things called dry cards
which are fantastic and worked quite
well of course we had to test it we're
not going to just go into something
without testing it in the in the gene
bank at symmet we had um
grain where we measured the the humidity
with our own instruments and then we put
the cards in and what you can see is
that they really nicely do
uh cover the range of um
where you want to be so you want to be
below 12
grain humidity and you can see that that
they do um really
monitor that and track that
so we also needed a way to monitor the
seed viability
where everyone in the community could
see it
and while we were on one of our trips
we noticed that
some some of the farmers had
had sand benches right and we thought
cool this would be a way where we could
plant out the seed that we dried in
different ways and show people in the
community how this works
also i had had some experience with sand
benches uh working in my first maze
genetics lab and i also knew that a
certain person named kevin ahern had
the sand bench hole puncher so when i
came home for a home leave i i stopped
in with kevin
and he graciously lent me
his one and only sand bench hole punch
which makes
50 seed plots
i took that thing back to mexico i took
it to guatemala i took it all over the
place
and we eventually built our own and i
gave kevin back his um but
we
used incorporated this into our
experiment um also our seed conditioning
team needed to kind of redesign the lid
for the uh that they they were using
because the lids are opaque of the ones
that they used in the uh
in the sea reserves and in order to
monitor you want to be able to not have
to take the top off you know you want to
maintain whatever the humidity is in
there and so um one of our our team
built they they made this uh this new
new setup
um so we decided to do in 2019
um also the other piece that that
happened is um
since i was two years out from um
from uh
retiring um i was i was given the
opportunity to have a postdoc which was
fantastic i wish i'd had postdocs from
the get-go
anyway um but uh i got this great
postdoc philippe busson who's a seed
biologist and i convinced him he needed
to go to guatemala and he was all for it
so we were able to you know get this
going so these hypotheses we wanted to
test seed quality and viability are
maintained better
when the seed is dry with drying beads
very simple very straightforward
seed quality viability maintained better
in hermetically sealed containers also
straightforward
and
seeds stored in community reserves is
maintained better than seed stored in
family seed reserves
in number of the communities people were
not fully convinced by this whole
community reserve thing and so we felt
that this is part of our
um you know we're doing what they call r
for d research for development which
means you're not you know away from
people you're working directly with
people with farmers and you need to
understand what their needs and
communicate well so um
that was another thing we needed to show
that in fact using community reserves is
a good thing
so uh
this is uh our experimental setup
each and we we
worked in three different communities
in each community there were two types
of reserve there was a reserve a family
reserve the farmer family and there was
the community reserve we had three
treatments and those are having seed in
net bag having seed in a plastic flask
that has not been dried and also having
seen the plastic flask that has been
dried so this is the this is the basic
setup and each of those little sets
went out to these different locations
and we also put a data logger in in
every location uh to keep track of um
temperature and humidity and um
that's how we we got going these
communities had three pretty different
environments
high high altitude meat kind of a little
bit medium and then more tropical in san
francisco and so uh
colder to hotter
less temperature to more temperature
variation um more or less humidity so
these were different quite different
environments
here we go the sand bench hole puncher
in action uh we made our own sand bench
at symmet we of course we have to try it
before we go out and do it so this was
us doing our first our first setup so
you see each each one of the little
plots 50 seeds and um
100 seeds sorry
and
so there we go and now this is what it
looks like in situ so this is like
gorilla science here i we are out there
um doing what we have to do where
in any way we can do it but here we have
the three sand benches in the three in
the three communities
we had to have covers on them to keep
the chickens and the dogs and everybody
out of there
um we did the humidity monitoring um by
visiting twice we set it up then at
three months and then at six months and
each time we downloaded the data from
the logger to keep track of that
and
as you can see um
in the beginning uh if you look in this
side you've got the the pink cards in in
the slash where the seed has not been
dried and the blue cards are where the
seed has been dried
uh we did a grain quality measurements
and this is
the counting percent of intact seeds
from a random sample of 100 seeds so
those are the the kind of data that we
were collecting
and here let's look at the data so um
this is what it looked like just for
seed dried with beads and stored in
hermetic flask so this is the best
possible situation and as you can see
after three months after six months it's
it's good there are no statistical
differences between
those three data points and this is this
is for
our um
for that that treatment so
there we go okay what happens if you
don't draw the beads and you put them in
a hermetic flask
well
all those eggs that went in there and
did not get killed they're they're
hatching and they're destroying the seed
okay and it gets worse and worse
depending on the heat depending on you
know san francisco is a more tropical
location and we're practically down to
nothing by the end the other thing to
note is that
the there was no difference between what
was going on in the community reserves
and the farmers that's why we combine
the data so it was a very simple story
here
um
the net bags was a little it's kind of
was kind of interesting because the net
bags
of course they're exposed to the insects
and the
and the temperature but they're also
there is air flow and so in fact in some
cases the net bags did
not great but they didn't do too well
too badly but
the pattern was a slightly different
depending on the environment and
depending on you know how how much
insect pressure you had
um
the seed quality uh also same same deal
uh but what was happening
what was happening there was that uh
there was a little more nuance um in
especially the tropics there were there
were differences between what happened
it was much worse much worse in the
farmer's sea reserve than than in the in
the
community reserves so
bottom line here
uh our hypotheses our results uh
yes
yes using drying beads in hermetically
sealed class
always the best in no matter what the
environment what the reserve type is
um
so is seed quality viability maintained
better in a hermetically sealed
container only if you dry the seed first
okay
does the seed do better in the community
reserves
not necessarily and it depends more on
the storage quality okay how good
the farmer's reserve is but also the the
series definitely shows some technical
advantages for instance the temperature
was much more much lower and more stable
in the community reserves and
there was more consistent pest control
so
still the community reserves are a
better bet
so now this is what we ended up this is
what we are proposing now for the
community reserves a few more steps in
here when they when the farmers arrive
with their seed they do a dry car test
to say okay is this water dry if it's
dry great
put it right into the private account
bucket if not
do go through a drying cycle in um this
is this is a dry store psych
silo for drying
uh and then once it is dry it can go
into the flask and then
it have monitoring but remember the
monitoring can be very simple can be
once a month look at the cards is
anything what is anything dry if it's
wet put it in the silo and dry it down
if it's wrong fantastic the thing you
have to realize is all this work in
community reserves almost all of it is
volunteer and these are very busy
farmers and these are very remote
regions
when the farmers come and bring their
sea they have walked many of them have
walked for hours to get there they
arrive and their seeds wet
the guys at the reserve are like oh man
this is what can you like take it back
home put it out in the sun and bring it
back
invariably they're like no i'm not going
to do that so they have to have a way to
get that seed dry so this is this is the
the setup that we we um
we proposed and we we went back in the
communities and talked about doing this
so in the case of guatemala we didn't
only do tech transfer we also sent
germplasm and um over the course of this
project we repatriated to the national
system of guatemala
785 music sessions that at one time they
had
but they lost because someone turned off
the
the generator and
went for a week or so and they lost the
entire entire collection but
we had the the entire national
collection at cement and we were able to
repatriate it but the cool thing is that
when we brought it back it went to our
collaborators who did regeneration
nurseries there and were able to do a
selection process to figure out what's
the best germplasm so
uh that was what we did now
now after we had this great success
we're all excited about doing it in seed
reserves um
what about using drying drying beads in
in germplasm banks and and breeding
programs can we apply
and why not
so um we had a great example that we
could use at scent
at the tropical station agua
they had this huge old drying cabinet
that was bought in 1967 so it was
probably the first thing they bought for
this station then it started in 1966.
anyway the breeders had decided they
didn't like this
anymore because it didn't get hot enough
so they weren't using it we asked if we
could just kind of retrofit it and play
with it and they were like yeah whatever
you want take it we don't care so we
decided to convert it with drying beads
so
uh
you can see what we did here this is
kind of a side view you see that they
did a nice paint job they made it look a
lot better
but we made the inside work better and
we had to do a little bit of work on the
fan but otherwise we were able to keep
the air flowing air is flowing through
the drying beads so the air coming out
at the other side is very dry air and
we're able to recycle it
um so we use about four to eight kilos
of drying beads and um
and we did this experiment so so wha
what's the problem the problem for the
germplasm bank is it takes us weeks to
dry our harvested seed using unheated
forced air in our drying room so we
wanted to try something different um and
uh but if we dry using drying beads and
it's a rapid drying system does that
have a detrimental effect on the
longevity or seed we're very concerned
about that that's what we're in this
business for is to keep seed for long
periods so what filippo organized was
doing a controlled aging test
and this is something that
physiologists do
what they do is they um
create the worst possible
uh situation for seed they put seed in
and then they they do um
they keep um sampling at at uh time
points
and they look at they track the
longevity so basically they're trying to
speed up
you know we can't wait 50 years to find
out that we killed all our cds and
dragons we need to simulate that so this
is a way of simulating this is the
protocol that we use
you can see the seeds are exposed to 60
relative humidity and 45 degrees c
and this is what happened
when we did the the set of seeds in the
aguafria using rapid drying it took us
four days to dry that seed
in el baton which is headquarters where
the bank is it takes 21 days to get to
the same so we had these two sets of
seed we did uh we looked at the
longevity curve and we found out that
there's no difference so
this is a very important piece of
information because now we can without
problems we can
without um doubts we can
we can now use it for germplasm banks
and reading programs too
so here's a story of seed banks or seed
more
major good men is a super well-known
plant breeder
um
and germplasm expert at nc state he was
a guru mentor of ed's and many other
people and um in 1990 he made this
statement which everyone in the
germplasm bank world knows major goodman
says seed banks are seed morgues
it was very catchy phrase um but when
you look at the what he actually wrote
in in this paper
it's a little more nuanced okay
and what he said was um a germplasm
system that merely acquires material and
does not have facilities for evaluation
utilization is really not a system
and in many cases i would maintain that
that seed bank is a seed more and that
that i i totally am on board with him on
that so of course
a lot of the work we did at simon had to
do with
evaluation
and
utilization was something that was
part of how the bank began because the
bank began
with the starting breeding populations
for simmet's reading program
so here's major governor even though he
said bad things about about germ
pleasant banks
he and that's garrison wilts as a
tsuntae guru
they came to a meeting we had in 2016 of
the international maze genetic resources
advisory committee so this is something
you got to remember when people start
dumping [ __ ] on what you do those are
the people you need to be talking to
because they are going to help you
you're going to help you get better and
so we of course had to have major come
and join us and criticize us and and
give us uh challenges and
we still love him so much anyways so
also we decided to uh do a project where
we understood better
what the what are seeds doing in the
bank
a scheduled monitoring system for seed
germination had not been set up at this
germ plaza bank this now we're talking
about symmet the international germplasm
bank
until 2012. so it wasn't me it wasn't
like my arrival that said hey we gotta
have germany they had already started
but it was 2012 when scheduled
monitoring started happening
so really there was a lot that we didn't
know about the collection
so um we wanted to compare we have two
different kinds of vaults
active chamber and
uh base chamber two different
temperatures we wanted to see
are there differences in the longevity
of the seed in these two locations
and can we identify groups or types of
accessions that maybe need
more frequent monitoring than others
okay we didn't know that we didn't know
any of this
eventually this is something that's in
progress now um
they want to look at can we can we
identify molecular markers that are
associated with seed longevity that's
part of you know the next next stage of
this project
um
so
eventually what we had was um
accessions from the base collection the
cold really the cold vault
and from the active collection and um in
835 cases we had the same accessions
from both locations so we were able to
do a direct comparison
uh we also had to be careful about um
making sure that we had uh accessions
that had been
been checked when they entered the
collection and then had maybe
two or three monitoring um
tests
so um
this is the traits that we're measuring
and
longevity or aging rate which is how um
how slow or how fast the seed
is aging that was what was used for the
data here
so the data collection um
was basically making what what people in
the bank called tacos so making making
um
these uh
rolled filter paper seed germination
just like you know everybody did in
kindergarten well we do a lot of that
and uh
scoring after one after one week and uh
this is the results so
very interesting yes
um
in the active chamber and that's the
chamber where we go in to get
seed for distribution
uh where it's a little warmer it's you
know it's around freezing more or less
um
we found that there was significantly
lower uh viability in those seeds as
opposed to the base so it made a lot of
sense we had no numbers we had no idea
um we're pretty happy with these results
because um
even even for the uh in the active
collection 81 and it our collection 81
have
uh are are good have have that level of
viability
much better in the active chamber and
this was you know the first time we had
any idea about this
um also looking at what traits are
correlated with longevity and we found
that grain type
and also seed mass were two two
characteristics that were correlated
with
longevity
those two
and um it turns out that flint seeds
which
anecdotally people have said for a long
time they are longer lived
and they are the ones that um
on average they can have longer
monitoring intervals so this is the
interval between when you do tests so
this was calculated and um for them it's
about 20 20 years
so the you know why would you do all
this monitoring well
this will control how much regeneration
you have to do and that is i i often say
to my staff that's the most dangerous
place but it's the most fascinating
interesting place to be is when you're
regenerating an accession
because on the one hand you could lose
the accession on the other hand you
finally are seeing what that accession
does what it looks like how does it how
does it you know what what is what is it
it's a phenotype overall
and so uh but you don't want to have to
do that too often especially when you
have um
a collection as large as simmons
so here are the take home messages the
faster loss of seed viability observed
in the active chamber this suggests that
the current seed conservation approach
which i have to say is very common in
the international banks of using two
chambers with different temperatures
could be
counterproductive so using lower
temperature condition in both
in both of them is probably the way you
should be going
um
also the finding that there are
significant differences in seed
longevity among the accessions
indicates that there are different
viability monitoring and regeneration
intervals
for these different types of seeds
so this was something we had no idea
about
so i i've been talking a lot about
energy
and
energy conservation so i just last week
one of my colleagues kai saunder at uh
at symmet posted this cool drone picture
of this is simmit headquarters in mexico
and um
i think you'll notice that there's
something kind of interesting on the
roof of the cemet and um
there you see the little yellow circle
that's where the vault is that's where
the cement seed vault is the red circle
is
hey solar panels makes a lot of sense in
mexico
and uh by putting in these solar panels
we had a 70 offset on the electricity
and also at the same time
we kind of greened up the system and the
bank by um by changing out the cooling
compressors and making them ozone
compliant and more energy efficient so
uh this is the way we we dealt with that
so
when in 2016 um the whole genetic
resources group got together and we were
tasked with coming up with our you know
what's our objective
each scientist had to get up and say
this is my objective and this is what
i'm doing now i didn't want to do that i
thought that was really hokey but in the
end it actually was a good thing um
because when i was retiring from symmet
i was able to go back and say hey what
were my objectives anyway
and so
my big objective was to pass on a better
bank to my successor okay better than
the one i found in 2012.
and these were the things i said i was i
needed to do
the grin global database it had to be
fully operational this was the goal
um the regeneration success of these
accessions had to be at least 75 percent
i needed to have a complete set of
summit maze lines
all available for distribution it's a
big goal
oh there are over 600 of them
that there are no skeletons in the vault
so like there's no backlog of unknown
materials bags of stuff that we don't
know what's going on
um there was a lot of that when i got
there um
completely relabeled flasks in both the
vaults with functioning 2d barcodes okay
and i wanted to leave behind a team with
enough experience enough dedication that
they could even run the bank themselves
without a curator
so how well do we do
well
fully met gringlobal we were one of the
first international banks to take it on
to really really use it started using it
in distribution and then all the
functions of the entire bank got on
board and it's fully functional um we
got up to 79
in 2019 that was really exciting um yeah
we almost have all the cmls available
for distribution very close
um
no skeletons involved there is still a
backlog we have we had a two-thirds
reduction but everything is there we
know what it is and it's also in the
active process of regeneration
um
the late re-labeling of the flask this
took a hit because of covid um so we
only got
about one-third done on that but we had
that we had to put that aside
and focus only on distributions during
code time
um
and the last one the team with enough
experience i i feel like yes i did that
um
we have a team that's super dedicated
and ready to to do the whole story
i mean it may be a bit boring uh not
having a curator around especially one
like me is always coming up with crazy
things
so um
here we go with gratitude i have lots of
people to thank are all our partners in
dry chaining um we hope to keep going
with with a number of them but uh we had
quite a few
um also my my key collaborators
christian zavala is
he's the gene bank coordinator now he
was my uh
my head assistant and
he
did everything and he was involved with
all these projects and everything having
to do with the bank
originally from maze now he does it for
everything for maze and wheat um
carolina camacho is a
colleague and dear friend of mine in the
socioeconomics program and every project
we do with farmers i work with her
um felipe of course you've seen his
great work and um i couldn't do this
seed work without him
so um and also this is the staff
um of the entire bank both maze and
wheat teams
um the tallest maze there is holla maze
and that particular plan is uh five and
a quarter meters tall
and the tallest team in there is tom
payne he's the wheat curator
and he just retired just last month
so uh
of course we couldn't do any of this
without money so um and
we really really appreciated the
guidance of the crop trust they are the
people that manage the all the um
operating funds of the banks and they
really are give us a lot of good
guidance
um
and thank you all thank you for your
interest and um
i hope you enjoyed this crazy talk and
yeah
questions would be welcome thank you
[Applause]
questions
tim
uh simple question are the drying beads
silica gel and if so or how do you
regenerate them
um no they are not syllable gel it's a
special kind of ceramics and
ceramics they're they're like clay beads
and uh
but it's zeolite and the thing about
zeolite is that the pores
are the size of water molecule so the
water molecule goes in and cannot get
out it gets trapped the way they they
get rejuvenated is to put them in an
oven
so heat them in an oven at uh 250
degrees for two hours and you recover
them
and um that was a very interesting side
bit which i knew i didn't have time to
do although it's funny because
we're trying to figure out how are we
going to regenerate or
re-reactivate the beads you know in the
kuchimatani's mountains and it turns out
that every village
somebody has a
a
gas generator
um
operated oven for bread
so we were able to do it using one of
those ovens yeah um so uh so it's
possible and uh yeah that's how it works
okay there's oh can you uh click on the
chat
uh
do you have a question
go into another question
in the seat bank where you
i efficiently keep it well
with um i mean the the cla the um
the standard method for
for for uh maize and most things for
long-term storage is to not use heat is
to avoid heat
um
i mean yeah i mean i mean for the
breeders you only need the seed for you
know a couple years that could work
um
this might be a cheaper way to go
but yeah i mean that's that's possible
but but people stay away from heat when
yeah
i mean it could still be kind of like
household temperature 80 degrees
yeah i mean the thing is
most places have their their drying
chamber from the 1960s still you know so
yeah um in order to make it more
efficient you got to go some
different way out but yeah
hey i got the questions up somehow um
okay one of the questions from zachary
any thoughts on efficiently managing
pollen contamination with wind
pollinated crops
um well you know we
there we did exactly the same thing we
do here in the genetics labs uh
um
nurseries you know we we did complete
covering we did
we did
just just exactly like
we we do here so and everywhere so we
you know tassel bags shoot bags
you know
completely manual i mean that's the
difference between
wheat regeneration and maze regeneration
it's a it's a
the order of magnitude difference how
many accessions tom payne and his crew
can do a year
over what we could do in a year and it
was always like i
can't keep up with that at all
and they could like take a year off you
know we're like what
that's not a concept you know take a
year off um
so um
nothing
nothing out of different out of the
ordinary we were doing the same thing
you know same bags lofts and bags i mean
same thing yeah
another question was any idea on what
percentage of cement maze germplasm is
being used by african breeders
oh um
well i mean the summit maze program is
based in kenya okay
and so uh they have you know complete
access to symmet maze lines
and you know we we
whenever they need supply of that and we
we send we send uh
you know whatever they need whenever
they need it they mostly have they can
regenerate their own stuff
there
um so
uh
yeah i mean that's
that's a question for the breeding
program but yeah i mean there's a very
active reading program and they they use
symmet
maze lines
we've had a lot of discussion about
whether you
uh you would
say that africa has land races okay
africa has had maize for 500 years so
that's a thousand generations so i would
say that
they've got some land races there
and um
iita which is the uh in nigeria
uh they have a maze program there
they're they're the only other
um
cg international uh system that does uh
institute that also does maze um besides
cement so um
you know we have a complete backup of
their question they they did they did
collect um from
you know what
you could call land races so we have
some of that material
um
so there are connections
for sure it looks like leecast has a lot
of questions about the beads so maybe
you can some of them you've already
answered but maybe you can follow up
later with on the cost of beads and
would they be appropriate to be used in
an herbarium
in the tropics
um there's another question um are all
cement accessions stored at negative 15c
today instead of negative 3 and negative
15c
yeah i mean i i probably didn't notice
but
the entire collection is in the base the
active plug there there are some cases
where we don't have it in the active but
we do have it in the base
um so ev everything in the collection is
in the base
and then a high proportion are also
inactive but um like even if you know
the in the experiment we had a thousand
accessions that came out of the base
and um you know 800 or so of those uh
we're also inactive so there there is a
little bit of a difference there but
everything in the collection is is in
the base
do we have any other questions from here
yes that has the questions about the
feeds
um are there any significant bottlenecks
with the manufacturing of the bees you
said it came from one central place in
thailand do they have the if you were to
supply all these regional and local
sperm plasms or seed banks also
uh would they have the scale of
production are you
kind of at their whim as the
supply of
these uh
okay so the original use for the zeolite
beads was to get water out of oil
so this this was from the oil industry
so
there is no like
bottleneck there and the oil industry
has a lot i mean but i mean not a lot
but they you know there's a lot of those
out there
the innovator who said hey we can use
these beads for drying plant material in
thailand he has his own company and he
does all this fancy fancy stuff
there is now a distributor in the u.s
dry chain america is a distributor of
all things related to drying beads um
but if you go online
and you look for zlips you can get them
you know i mean i don't know if amazon
has them but
but
you can get them i mean they come from
china
so uh
you know the the guy in thailand is
always trying to kind of keep a lock on
on people who are using it for drying
plant but he can't i mean plant material
so
um this was a big deal for us we had
when we did that experiment in guatemala
we could not bring the beads in unless
we had a special permit because the
beads don't exist in guatemala we had to
have this special
uh
registration thing and we couldn't get
it and
and
i it delayed the experiment by a year
and then when filippo came i said hey
filippo how about if you and i carry
them in backpack over the border
um from mexico to guatemala
and he was like cool
so we did that
so we actually smuggled into guatemala
right
um
we called it smuggling for good you know
i mean there were a lot of people going
the opposite direction with other things
but we were going to guatemala and we
were bringing we were going to save the
farmers of guatemala so um
we can get them in mexico though
we can order them and get them from
mexico especially now
our first shipment came from thailand
and like doubled the price of them
but now they come from the
there's a distributed in the u.s dry
chain america and you can get them from
him
so
all right well i have one final question
where do you think germplasms need to be
going in their future to really become
instead of being these morgues
places where innovation is starting but
is not the end of the mandate to just
keep them the seeds rejuvenated
uh well
you know i like to have fun i like to
work with the farmers and so i just like
made time to do that right but as you
can see i mean the reason why i include
that last bit where i'm showing my goals
and doing it is because there's a lot of
stuff to do there's a lot of maintenance
to do
so you have to have
a good well-trained team you have to
have everything you need i mean you need
a man a really strong mandate and i have
to say that over the you know the eight
years i was there we did have uh you
know the funding stream was was pretty
solid and um and we were creative and
one year the giz german government
people said
we are not going to give you
our 300 000 this year and we're like
what
and and they said we want to fund
technology
so tom payne's like
let's get solar panels
and
and you know the germans love that kind
of stuff and yeah we got solar panels so
you know you have to be like creative
you have to keep
keep moving like that you know and and
trying to find a way to do it and i
think that's that's the only thing it's
just you know
just keep pushing and and
keep your priorities really straight in
your mind
no i don't want my seed bank to become a
morgue of course that should be
top priority there uh but i want to make
sure people can use it and know about it
you know like i was telling moira like
so many farmers when we talked to they
were like they had no idea there was
something like that in their country
and um
so we need to get out there and talk to
people and and really uh
you know
make it more accessible
all right well thank you if we could
give denise a round of applause
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu